right under Belgium but I think the key
message I wanted to share today is it is
a fantastic time to be a new mathematics
teacher
the demand is phenomenal as a newly
appointed head teacher I'm saying with
myself this year I've had two teachers
leave and I have two more about to
retire and taught me to my colleagues
and now it's the same across Sydney that
baby boomers are retiring they're
retiring big time we're desperate for
new teachers there's any one problem the
job ads say we want the experience and
normally that would like experience an
extension one an extension to a job
don't despair in the current shortage
and there is a shortage teacher head
teachers and selection panels are making
compromises they will take less
experience but you have to inspire
confidence than it's worth them taking
that risk is it is a big risk you're
thinking about a year 11 or 12 classes
in particular you are terrified that the
parents are going to say why are you
putting inexperienced teachers in charge
of my class so I think one of your goals
is to be able to put yourself in a
position that when someone like me or
selection panel sees your interview that
sees your CV that we feel the confidence
in
worth to interview and the advice I'm
gonna give you today is there is one
thing you can do they will absolutely
guarantee guarantee but greatly
increases the chance that you will get
the phone call that says we would at
least like to talk to you and that thing
is a really strong recommendation from a
head teacher who has seen you teach I'll
say it again a recommendation from a
head teacher who has seen you teach that
is worth gold
that is worth absolute gold that a
selection panel can see a name of a key
teacher as a referee and they go truth
is most people know everybody in the
business it's a small business now look
at that now you'd say that person is
willing to put their name against that
person and say they're good and if we
get around to picking up the phone and
talking to that person the very first
thing we wanna hear is have they seen
that person teach if they haven't seen
that person teach then really what
they're talking about is just their
wishes their confidence and their
inspiration but what we're really
looking for is have we seen half that
doesn't seem to teach how do they talk
about their teaching and then you can
ask them questions that relate to the
context of your school you know what
your students are like you can say how
does that person teach with respect to
these issues so my first big message is
you need to get in a position where a
head teacher has seen you teach and not
just once over a period um how long I
don't think it actually has to be that
long I think after about two or three
months if a head teacher has seen you
teach and other colleagues have seen
and you've interacted you can get that
type of recommendation you get one
really free stop everyone in this room
gets one free shot that's your
internship you need to make that
internship work your career as well as
their professional development so my
advice to you is from a career point of
view which I don't think is
contradictory to a teacher development
point of view you need to really work on
getting that recommendation from that
head teacher you want to be in a
position that if that school has got a
free teaching block the next year and
there is a good chance that they do that
they will immediately think we want that
into they know who you are they know
what you did
they've seen that you're a valuable
member of the faculty many of things you
Cobra the first two speakers I give you
very specific thing so I'm very good one
there's get involved in the school get
involved in the school that gets noticed
that gets noticed by principals that get
noticed by their teachers those students
I'll just say one or two things and very
close okay all right so just a few
little tips to getting that
recommendation the first thing is you
absolutely must get a good working
relationship with all the teachers in
your new faculty that you're going to
every single teacher in there has got
something to teach you find out what
they've got to teach you there's going
to be one or two do just that faculty
you think you don't want
interact with you don't give up on them
give it a try right one more leave me
the headteacher even if they're not
supervising your classes you need to
work with them see if you can watch
vintage see if you can get them to watch
you too much